al caer la noche las calles de kiev
quedan a oscuras sumiendo a este barrio
en las sombras
es el segundo día consecutivo que los
habitantes se quedan sin electricidad
los ataques rusos han puesto a prueba la
red eléctrica de la ciudad
apagamos la nevera para ahorrar
electricidad los ciudadanos se han visto
obligados a adoptar medidas de ahorro de
energía
usamos el balcón
Mira para mantener la comida fresca
hay algunos vecinos que todavía
mantienen las luces encendidas pero el
alcalde de kiev ha instaurado cortes de
luz rotatorios de 4 horas la calefacción
central también se ha reducido a pesar
de las gélidas temperaturas del exterior
tenemos muchas mantas para el invierno
cuando hace frío nos ponemos ropa de
abrigo en casa en nuestra casa no hay
camisetas hasta que se alcancen Entre 10
y 15 grados bajo cero Eso funcionará
bien
durante el invierno la temperatura pude
alcanzar los 20 grados bajo cero todo
tras ataques deliberados de las fuerzas
armadas rusas a las centrales eléctricas
creando deliberadamente la actual
escasez en las últimas dos semanas han
destruido el 30% de la infraestructura
energética de Ucrania por no hablar de
antiguas zonas de combate como irping un
suburbio de kiev que fue escenario de
una batalla que duró un mes entre
febrero y marzo
hoy vamos a trabajar con cables vamos a
reparar dos líneas eléctricas
siete meses después la red eléctrica aún
no está totalmente preparada
recientemente las sedes de las empresas
eléctricas como Tech se han convertido
en objetivo para los rusos
como puede ver la mayoría de la gente
prefiere trabajar desde casa y la
empresa ofrece la oportunidad de educar
porque creemos que el hogar ahora es más
seguro para la gente
la mayor empresa Privada de energía de
Ucrania intenta mantener las luces
encendidas pero
su director general las medidas de
ahorro de energía No son suficientes
Ucrania necesita ayuda extranjera para
preparar su infraestructura energética y
armas para protegerla
el problema más acuciante es como montar
una defensa aérea suficiente es la única
manera de estabilizar la situación y
proteger nuestra infraestructura
sin calefacción podría haber una nueva
oleada de refugiados este invierno